two small states both neighbors to a
much larger more powerful and
threatening authoritarian power that
frequently bullies them
as unlikely as a blossoming friendship
between the tiny baltic state of
lithuania and taiwan might be perhaps
the two have more in common than at
first glance lithuania is worried about
russia and taiwan is worried about china
their relationship has upset beijing
it was particularly angry when taiwan
opened a representative office a de
facto embassy in lithuania's capital
vilnius and there have been a string of
retribution ever since most recently a
demand that multinational companies cut
ties with lithuania or risk being shut
out of the china market
well
meanwhile in taipei the new friendship
continues as dw's joyce lee reports
ricardo sadenkines moved to taiwan three
years ago one of just 22 lithuanians
living on the democratic island he's
excited to see closer ties between
taiwan and his home country when i first
time came here in taiwan it was first
asian country i visited
and for me i thought
that would be
so great many more people to come from
europe to learn from this culture i was
so impressed so
what's happening
between lithuania and taiwan this is
kind of fulfillment of one of my
greatest dreams but his taiwanese wife
and friends are worried about the
consequences for their friendship with
lithuania
the price of befriending lithuania is
our economic interests with china but i
think for us the younger generation
values such as freedom are more
important than money
why
uh
foreign if i had to choose between china
and lithuania i'd still choose china
after all china's closer to us and has a
bigger market
i support closer ties with lithuania but
i think we shouldn't do it too high
profile and trigger china
ties flourished between the two after
lithuania donated coffee vaccines to
taiwan last summer then taipei opened a
representative office in the baltic
state beijing reacted furiously blocking
all imports from lithuania and even
recalled its ambassador but lithuania
has no intention of backing down last
week a delegation of lithuanian
lawmakers met with taiwan's president
tainwon both sides emphasized the
importance of democracy
for them you can feel how being a
democracy in this geopolitical
circumstances is so important for them
uh
and i feel responsible
you feel responsible because you
understand you represent europe
they
catching every real world they are like
it's like lithuania in 1991 before the
collapse of soviet union when lithuania
declared its independence we was
catching every word from the west we was
hoping for legit legitimization
for ricardus ricardo's attentiveness
this lithuanian candy store in taipei
used to be his little-known place to get
a taste of home but the shop became
famous in the past few months sales have
gone up tenfold since the vaccine
donation
many taiwanese bought chocolates to
express gratitude and people were moved
by lithuania's friendliness and courage
to stand up for taiwan
that drove up our sails
the shop in many ways now symbolizes the
solid friendship between taiwan and
lithuania despite all the political
pressure from beijing
you